>>Narrator: In this converted navy
facility near the San Diego Airport
thoughtfully applied technology
is transforming public education.
>>We're going to want to focus on the
advertising throughout the school.
>>Larry: They're doing things,
they're producing things
so the purpose "tech" in High
Tech High is not for consumption.
It's for production.
>>Narrator: A former high school
carpentry teacher with a law degree,
Larry Rosenstock became
founding principal and C.E.O.
of High Tech High in 1998.
>>I tell our visitors who come
here "Stop any child that you want,
grade six through twelve at random
and ask them what they're working
on and watch what happens."
They'll look you in the
eye and they'll talk to you
about what they're working on.
>>Alex: So what we're going to
do in this class is we're going
to make a movie or like a
documentary on everything we learn.
We're learning about physiology
but we're also learning about like
after effects which
makes videos and stuff
so we're bringing them together.
>>Narrator: High Tech's 2,500
students gain entrance by a lottery
and represent a cross-section of San
Diego's public school population.
>>Jeffrey: Okay, trace it out.
>>Narrator: And whether they choose
to focus on the arts or sciences all
of them are engaged
in rigorous projects.
>>Teacher: And the one thing
we want to be careful about is
that we don't add your DNA
to these samples and you come
out in the end with your DNA barcode-
>>Narrator: In an 11th grade biology
class students are developing a DNA
barcoding process that will help
African law enforcement officials
convict poachers.
>>Teachers: These are photos
that I got last week from one
of our collaborators in Nairobi.
This is an eland.
>>I know everyone is really serious
about it because it's a serious issue
but this is really a lot
more fun than you'd be able
to do in any other classroom.
>>A lot of people donate stuff
because we are a non-profit.
>>Narrator: Whenever
possible, projects are designed
to serve the local community whether
it's creating a storage system
for the YMCA.
>>David: We have a
new storage facility-
>>We can actually take this out.
>>Narrator: Or designing an
assistive technology device.
>>David: She used it for the
first time and moved that bar up
and down the paper for
the first time herself.
Her eyes just lit up.
It was the first time that she'd
been able to do something on her own
and it was just the students were
tremendously touched, I was touched.
It was just a really
amazing experience.
>>What's going on here?
>>It's a fat that builds up.
>>Narrator: Instead of grades on high
stakes tests at the end of the year,
students are assessed
on an ongoing basis.
>>Rob: Assessment is not an
endpoint; it's not an end activity.
It's something that
goes on moment to moment
so teachers are always checking for
kids' understanding and so forth
and we're always asking kids to in
a lot of different contexts to kind
of describe what it
is they're working on,
what it is they've
discovered, what their plan is
for the next day and so on.
So assessment is folded in.
>>Jeffrey: Good work guys.
>>Student: Alright, thanks.
>>Narrator: They are also judged on
their individual digital portfolios
and their stand-and-deliver
presentations of learning.
>>Student: I will start this
presentation of learning today
with math and physics
followed by Spanish I
and finishing off with humanities.
>>Christopher: Instead of taking
finals at our school we do POLs,
which is a presentation of
learning where we get up in front
of the whole class and the
teachers and a whole panel of people
and tell them exactly what we learned
this year, how it can be applied
to real life, and how you've
developed in critical thinking
or developed in other things.
>>Narrator: Students are also
assessed on their contributions
to group projects like books on
the ecology of San Diego Bay.
Larry: These are really high
quality efforts by kids as opposed
to memorizing 3,000 biology
words to prepare for the AP exam.
We want kids behaving
like scientists,
and behaving like photographers,
and behaving like graphic artists.
>>Narrator: The High
Tech model is working.
>>Student: Point one
which is that line-
>>Narrator: The original high
school has grown into a network
of eight public charter schools.
>>Jeffrey: And maybe you
could put that same kind
of text here, here, and there.
>>Narrator: And 100 percent
of High Tech High graduates
are accepted to college.
>>Jeffrey: I really
believe in this place.
I've been here since the beginning
and I think it is absolutely
the true way to learn.
>>Gabby: And the brown is
fine in the background?
>>Jeffrey: Yeah the brown is fine
as long as you put those words in.
>>Okay, thank you, Okay?
>>For more information on what works
in public education
go to edutopia.org